einmal star ist gerne mutter hat uns
hingesetzt und gesagt euer vater wird
nicht mehr nach hause kommen nach nine
eleven wurden sie von allen zu helden
gemacht mein vater aber hätte gesagt wir
haben nur unseren job gemacht er wollte
immer nur anderen menschen helfen
[Musik]
ich habe keine fotos von leichen gemacht
siehst das war ein so intimer ort um zu
arbeiten wenn du es wurde mir klar dass
praktisch jeder der da war nach jemandem
gesucht hat den erkannte
[Musik]
ich habe gesehen dass alle gelitten
haben ich habe die feuerwehrleute und
rettungskräfte gesehen die eigentlich
die kontrolle haben sollten aber sie
wussten nicht was sie tun sollten wir
hatten nicht die fähigkeiten die meine
männer und ich hatten deshalb bin ich
geblieben um so viel zu helfen wie ich
konnte
[Musik]
über die letzten 20 jahre sehen wir mehr
leid und elend als gute zahlen an die
level
all die hindernisse die wir über kommen
mussten viele menschen sterben auch enge
freunde ich war bei 187 beerdigungen und
jedes mal wird es härter die folge fort
20 jahre sind vergangen und doch ist
dieser tag der welt verändert hat für
viele noch nicht vorbei
[Musik]
vier menschen haben wir getroffen deren
schicksal mit diesem tag eng verbunden
ist der sie nicht loslässt der sie an
vielem zweifeln lässt und ihnen doch
hoffnung gibt wir leben die ganz anders
verlaufen wären wäre dieser tag wie
jeder andere tag einfach nur zu in die
regale
oliver bis müller war 6 ist hätte
eigentlich ein glückstag werden sollen
auf dem langen weg zum erwachsen ich
hatte einen zahn verloren und hatte
gehofft dass militante etwas bringt bei
mir ein zahn fehlt ich wusste nicht das
ist mein vater ist li
bis vater war feuerwehrmann einer der
ersten die einen brennenden gebäuden
waren um die zu retten die alleine dem
inferno nicht entkommen konnten sie
haben seine überreste nicht gefunden und
um ehrlich zu sein bin ich ganz froh
darüber es hilft mir dabei zu glauben
dass seine seele in frieden ruht
der verlust des vaters keine zeit mehr
mit ihm verbringen zu können stellt früh
die weichen für ein außergewöhnliches
leben
wenn ich
war gerade elf als ich präsident george
darf ich meinen ersten brief geschrieben
und ihn gebeten habe unseren truppen
nach hause zu bringen und ich habe alle
meine klassenkameradinnen dazu gebracht
zu unterschreiben ich habe nie von ihm
zurück gehört also habe ich 12
geschrieben und gesagt bringen sie nach
hause man sollte ohne sein vater
aufwachsen so wie ich wir töten alle
dort was bringt das
auch der zweite brief bleibt
unbeantwortet
bisland arabisch studiert geschichte mit
dem schwerpunkt terrorismus will wissen
warum bin laden ihrem vater umgebracht
hat
es war echt hart mit dem trauma deinen
vater verloren zu haben aber es hat mir
die augen geöffnet ich habe verstanden
dass jeder einen grund hat etwas zu tun
ob du dem zustimmt oder nicht und er
hatte einen grund wütend auf unsere
regierung zu sein
während des studiums bekommt sie mo mi
do als buch konnten tagebücher in die
hand 14 jahre saß moorman du uns
schuldig in den berüchtigten us strafe
seine geschichte der mauretanier wurde
gerade mit tahar rahim jodie foster und
benedict cumberbatch in den hauptrollen
von hollywood verfilmt da wurde immer
wieder verhört und man hält ihn seit
sechs jahren fest oder eine einzige
anklage zu erheben
ich habe das buch gelesen und ich habe
mich schuldig gefühlt wie niemals zuvor
mir ist schlecht geworden ich habe mich
mitschuldig geführt ich musste mich bei
ihm entschuldigen ich musste ihm sagen
dass es mir leid tut denn sein leid ist
ja auch in unserem namen geschehen
heute sind
eng befreundet persönlich haben sie sich
aber noch nicht getroffen nur du lebst
in mauretanien roth stunden lang
tauschen sie sich über ihr leben der
videochat aus
der lippe bis arbeitet als beraterin bei
der ngo peace fotomodus sie will helfen
dass niemand mehr durch sinnlose gewalt
ob hier in amerika oder sonstwo auf der
welt sein vater verliert
[Musik]
ramona dies ist bei arbeiterin so wie es
ihr vater war der aus der
dominikanischen republik eingewandert
ist sie wurde in new york geboren
1973 in dem jahr in dem die beiden
mächtigen türme des world trade centers
eröffnet wurden ihr vater hatte als
schweißer die türme mit aufgebaut mein
vater hat mir erzählt dass es beim bau
schon viele unfälle und tote gegeben hat
harte arbeit stunde um stunde es war
grausam für ihn mitzuerleben wie dieses
riesenhaus zusammenstürzt in das er so
viel schweiß reingesteckt hat er war
sehr traurig als ich ihm eine der
spanien mitgebracht habe als die türme
zusammenstürzen mattig ramona sofort mit
ihrer attacke auf sie gehören mit zu den
ersten die sich in die hölle aus
blühenden reisen rauch und gestank
begeben in der chaos und agonie alles
handeln bestimmen ihr wird klar dass sie
so schnell von diesem ort nicht wegkommt
die entscheidung war klar ich habe die
feuerwehrleute und die polizisten
gesehen sie waren alle so verletzlich
und weinten wussten nicht was sie tun
sollten und ich habe mir gedacht wir
müssen denen jetzt zeigen dass wir als
stadt immer noch funktionieren also
dafür brauchst du beständigkeit mit
einem aber hatte sie nicht gerechnet wie
verzweifelt die lage war als ich die
crew reingebracht habe haben sie gefragt
was sie jetzt tun sollten ich habe sie
angesehen und gesagt ich bin nicht euer
boss was meint ihr und dann habe sie
gesagt du bist jetzt in charge da war
mir klar okay ich denke ich muss bleiben
sie müssen hier aufräumen
ramone nimmt das heft in die hand über
viele wochen wird sie das aufräumen was
übrig geblieben ist von dem was ihr
vater aufgebaut hat und sie erfährt in
all dem horror etwas das sie als
schwarze frau so nicht gekannt hat
ich bin wirklich keine rassisten aber es
war
da war die polizei die freunde der die
ärzte alle hatten eine andere hautfarbe
und sie waren demütig und bescheiden
du wirst nicht an die wand gestellt und
durchsucht und auf eine besondere art
und weise behandelt
es war die tragödie energie
zusammengekommen sind die uns
zusammengebracht
dieser tag habe ihr kraft gegeben an
irland zu glauben und daran will sie
keinen zweifel lassen
ich war dabei als die feuerwehrleute wir
alle die fahne aufgestellt haben um zu
zeigen wir sind immer noch da ihr habt
uns nicht in die knie gezwungen es ist
verrückt ich weiß aber ich habe mit dem
flagge auf den rücken tätowieren lassen
wir sind eins ich liebe meine flagge
ganz besonders wegen nine eleven an dem
tag an dem wir alle zusammen gekommen
sind
ein gefühl das universum entfernt von
ground zero und all dem was dieser tag
vor 20 jahren in der welt verändert hat
andrea burri ist zu reha hier ich hatte
schwere nebenhöhlen probleme und später
dann kam der krebs der mir raus genommen
wurde und seit kurzem abwicklung
probleme es hat auswirkungen auf
praktisch alle von uns auf die eine oder
andere weise
sie ist in utah als die türme
zusammenstürzen und der anruf kommt wie
jeder andere habe ich das am morgen
verfolgt und dann kam der anruf von der
katastrophenschutzbehörde
sie sagten ich solle nach denn sie
wollen so schnell wie möglich ein team
nach new york bringen
andreas krieg und krisen fotografien
amerikanische katastrophenschutzbehörde
wollte dass sie und ein kollege das
desaster dokumentieren kein fotograf des
schnelleren und besseren zugang
was so anders an nine eleven war war die
enorme empfindlichkeit an diesem ort
denn viele der feuerwehrleute und
polizeikräfte eigentlich alle die an den
rettungsarbeiten beteiligt waren haben
nach leuten gesucht die sie kannten
sie dokumentiert die extrem gefährlichen
search and rescue operationen in der
hölle aus stahl beton glas wochen lang
brennt und blüht es in dem sich
permanent bewegen den gebirge aus sport
eine sache die mir noch sehr gut in
erinnerung ist besonders am anfang war
die angst wenn die sirenen los gegangen
sind denn das hat bedeutet dass
möglicherweise ein weiteres gebäude
einstürzt und es gab einige orte an
denen du wusstest du wirst es nicht
schaffen aus dem geröll rauszukommen du
bist zu weit weg oder zu tief unten
trennen und trotz aller gefahr und angst
der ort lässt sie nicht los über wochen
dokumentiert sie den horror die
zerstörung aber auch kameradschaft
hoffnung die arbeit aber macht sie wie
so viele andere krank eingeschworene
gemeinschaft der arbeiter und
rettungskräfte am ground zero ist sich
im eifer ihrer arbeit einer gefahr nicht
gewusst
niemand hatte zeit darüber nachzudenken
es war eine erleichterung als die
umweltbehörde dann gesagt hat sie hätte
die luftqualität untersucht und keine
giftstoffe gefunden das war eine
erleichterung denn natürlich haben wir
alle diese wollten diesen gelben rauch
gesehen und weißt du im nachhinein meist
vollkommen bizarr dass wir nicht mehr an
unsere eigene gesundheit gedacht haben
[Musik]
so dass hier ist die feel good
foundation eine menge leute denken die
feel good foundation hätte ein großes
gebäude in new york city aber seit 17 18
jahren ist das hier der ort an dem ich
lebe und arbeite ich bin eigentlich ein
einzelgänger aber ich habe gelernt sehr
extrovertiert zu sein
john barr bauarbeiter als ihm bei den
aufräumarbeiten an ground zero ein
herabfallender stahlträger das bein
zertrümmert mehr als 40 operationen hat
er hinter sich aber immerhin erlebt seit
20 jahren setzt er sich für die 1 die
nicht so viel glück hatten wie er in
unserem land in der ganzen welt auch in
deutschland frankreich spanien verstehen
die leute nicht dass zehntausende
menschen krank geworden viele sind
mittlerweile gestorben
ist der längste tag in der geschichte
aller tage
er ist für viele noch nicht vorbei die
immer noch krank werden
viele sehr viele der polizisten
bauarbeiter feuerwehrleute
rettungskräfte die über wochen
ungefiltert die giftige wolke der
zerstörung aus asbest feinstaub und
gasen einatmen erkranken schwer
[Musik]
das war eine extrem giftige suppe wir
haben darin gearbeitet gegessen
geschlafen geweint durch mund nase und
haut haben wir das aufgenommen sind
krank geworden
krebs ist eine der häufigsten diagnosen
nine eleven wird ein entschädigungsfonds
aufgelegte aber schnell aufgebraucht ist
und immer mehr menschen erkranken
brauchen finanzielle hilfe die
republikaner im kongress aber kürzen
leistungen und verhindern weitere
zahlungen aber sie haben die rechnung
ohne john und seine jungs gemacht
die jungs sind absolut hardcore bridge
ist einer von ihnen wir sind new yorker
wir reden kein scheiß wir nehmen keine
gefangenen wir sagen dir ins gesicht was
sache ist
immer wieder fahren sie nach washington
machen persönlich druck auf die
senatoren
2015 hatte ich einen termin beim
matchmaking
vier bodyguards mit schnellfeuergewehren
haben mich eskortiert als sei ich ein
terrorist
was für eine
ich habe niemals gewalt angewendet
aber sie hatten angst haben sich
wahrscheinlich gedacht der kerl ist zu
allem bereit er hat ja nichts mehr zu
verlieren ich habe für zehntausende
menschen gekämpft wie größe
und er gewinnt den kampf mit der hilfe
von jon stewart einem amerikanischen
fernsehen superstar und
luke gibt den ausschlag nanni levon war
polizist der new yorker form squad ein
schrank von einem mann 18 jahre später
schwer vom krebs gezeichnet gibt er mit
johns jungs in washington eine
pressekonferenz das land und auch den
senat mit nur zwei gegenstimmen der
republikaner wird 2019 ein gesetz
verabschiedet das die zahlungen bis 20
92 sichert
der kampf hätte nie geführt werden wir
müssen die einstellungen ändern gewählte
offizielle sind keine rockstars oder
promis sondern staatsdiener die für uns
arbeiten
nine eleven hat jones neben geprägt was
er vor der vergeltung für diesen tag der
sein leben verändert hat hält dem krieg
in afghanistan wollen wir noch von ihm
wissen wir hätten niemals da reingehen
dürfen vier regierungen haben versagt
wie in wills weise verantwortlich machen
zwei republikanische zwei von den
demokraten sie lagen alle falsch jeder
einzelne
joe biden respekt der hat die eier da
rauszugehen dieser tag vor 20 jahren hat
amerika hat die welt verändert und
vielleicht wäre die geschichte anders
verlaufen wenn man denen zugehört hätte
die die größten opfer an diesem tag
gebracht haben
[Musik]